ladies and gentlemen from deadline Jim
Caviezel Thriller sound of Freedom
knocks Insidious Red Door from number
one spot they can't just ride it can
they write the headline
sound of Freedom box office number one
just write that
they had to write in such a way that you
they don't they don't say it even in the
article they don't explicitly say they
just say like it hit four million
dollars and then Red Door was 3.5 so
knocked down from just say sound of
freedom is number one ladies and
gentlemen with uh your viewing of the
film your support this film about child
trafficking is number one
the reason why I'm so excited for it
parallel economy obviously it's a good
movie you should see it obviously child
trafficking is bad but there are a lot
of ways about a lot of issues that we
watch okay this is about indie films
Shifting the cultural narrative onto
issues that we need to talk about
problems that need to be stopped that
for a long time they claimed weren't
really happening in the weirdest of ways
the Epstein stuff they said oh that's
nonsense and then he got arrested for it
and then Max Maxwell got convicted for
it and then prince Andrew got ostracized
and shunned for his involvement and
there's a lot of people on that client
unless we want to know about now this
movie comes out after five years they
try and shut it down and this is what
you can see a film about an important
issue number one it's a good film it's
got a 100 audience score in Rotten
Tomatoes even the critics like it
overall I mean it's like 80 percent
that's true critics enjoy it yup as much
as they want to rag on it and say it's a
q Anon film the majority of critics are
like a movie eighty percent
and now that's number one let's keep
supporting films like this so that we
can have alternatives to Hollywood and
the creepy grooming stuff that they try
and do in these films and the weird woke
ideology this is that path you know part
of what makes this movie so great I saw
it last night is Jim Caviezel is really
feeling this stuff I mean you can see it
in his eyes there's just it's enough of
his eye like you are with him you're in
his mind space and it is so powerful I
don't know what he went through to get
into this place where he's at right now
but God bless Jim Caviezel Batman yeah
he's a good actor I mean he was in the
passion right remember yeah yeah yeah
yeah he hasn't really done anything
major I feel like since then like he's
kind of he just comes back for well this
was well there's a reason so there's a
famous story about how he was a while
ago yeah there's a famous story about
how he was cast in the passion Mel
Gibson called him and said hey do you
want to destroy your career awesome all
right let's do it did you see that the
passion oh yeah yeah we watched it
recently actually yeah we actually
rewatched it yeah I watched together
there's a lot I learned about uh in
terms of the politics of the era that I
didn't didn't know which I thought was
interesting uh in terms of this film it
was made five years ago so when you
mentioned like he hasn't been doing
stuff he actually was he was doing this
and then they blocked the film now let
me ask you guys why would Hollywood not
run a film like this I I can't imagine a
possible incentive they would have to
not want people to care about the issues
of child trafficking and other related
problems you know their response to it
just I mean they just tell on themselves
it's like why are you doing this at
least fake it you know like yep I don't
know they're kind of it puts them in a
catch-22 like they can't support it
because they don't want it exposed but
if they you know come out against it
like they have been it makes them look
suspicious as there's that there's
that Viral uh there's that Viral tweet
where it's a guy who was like a writer
one of these digital Outlets was
claiming he tweeted something like the
only reason conservatives keep
complaining about kids being shown
graphic materials because they secretly
want to show kids graphic material
lights and then it was like it's one of
those like defiant L's or whatever where
it's like the next one is writer name
so-and-so gets arrested for listening
images or something this is of course
this is all right this is it's one of
the only jokes the left has is you're
against this thing I bet you secretly
want to do that thing right that's why
this video was so good yeah thank you we
just released from yesterday but if you
like Believe In traditional marriage
like up you're secretly gay that's the
only explanation if you're like I want
uh literally with with every single
issue uh if if you're against grooming
oh well actually like you secretly want
a groom right um I'm not kidding I think
I've heard a version of this about
literally every topic it's true we get
that all the time on gays against
groomers yeah yeah you're like secret
groomers of course that's the only
reason that you'd oppose this I think
what's that line those protests too much
I think that's that's too much that
Shakespeare yes me thinks that's protect
that's too much and there is something
too
talking about how something is evil
maybe then they are the one that's
perpetrating it and they want everyone
to think they're not I understand that
methodology but that doesn't mean that
if you claim something is evil or wrong
that you secretly want to do it yeah all
the lady doth protests too much me
thinks we live in this we live in a
culture where so many horrible
degenerate things have been normalized
so it makes sense that people would pay
attention to that and want to fix that
but whenever you do it's well that's
kind of interesting that you pay so much
attention that's like well one of the
number one culture War issues in the
country right now you think it's weird
about children being abused sexually and
otherwise like you freak yeah this line
is fantastic it's basically accusing
someone of virtue signaling uh it is
Queen Gertrude in response to insincere
overacting of a character uh to prove
his uncle's guilt blah blah the lady
doth protests too much me thinks I'm
just going to say that to people now who
have ritual signaling it's a great play
if you haven't seen Hamlet before see it
see a good version of it uh Billy
Madison you know
so they're watching actors in the play
do this like faux scene about the murder
of I think it's about the murder of
Hamlet's father uh and then the mother's
like I had something's off about this
and she doesn't know that her husband
murdered her her old husband so her new
husband I could explain this way better
I don't want to spoil it that's why I'm
kind of now you're stamping around but
yeah four 500 year old play
um so Hamlet's mother's uh and his
father was killed in the beginning of
the play so then his uncle comes in and
marries his mother and turns out his
uncle killed his father
um but his mother doesn't know that and
she's looking at the play like
something's off about and they're trying
to it's a great absolutely phenomenal
story right we're gonna have to go check
I hope I got all that right I looked up
the I was in it I played Laertes the
current numbers for sound of freedom
from Box Office Mojo 49 million 497 837
so that's fantastic
it is Wednesday if every single person
watching this goes and sees it what is
that that's not gonna that's not enough
that's not enough we need everybody
every single person watching this to
bring their friends and family to go see
it so that this film can crack 100
million dollars let's do it look I'm I'm
willing to see it again uh I also think
that if you can it's good to contribute
to the free ticket
um funds that they have for people who
can't afford to go see the movie but
would like to have you heard about
there's a bunch of videos being shared
on social media of people being kicked
out of the theaters and getting refunded
no I haven't seen that yeah because
there's too many people there no no no
no reason it was actually I think
Newsweek reported this let me see if I
can uh they just don't they're trying to
prevent people from no idea
movie theater video shows so the report
actually brings up that there's several
different videos where people in various
theaters are told for some reason they
gotta Evacuate the theater and they're
given a refund and no explanation why
there's like Mr Smith's all over the
place trying to get people you know from
The Matrix trying to get people to not
see it they're just like oh no there's a
fire you have to leave a horrifically
horrifically awesome movie man I oh geez
it's it's a tough watch right I mean it
is there are parts that are very uh
painful and I I'm not sure how much I
can say without spoiling it but it
it almost um what's good about it is
at the end you do feel motivated to want
to do something because I don't think
like just given the nature of the
problem it's not a story that they can
just tie in any little bow like you get
that with Hollywood films a lot the
problem solved everything's fine and it
gives the audience a sense of
satisfaction it's a movie that you watch
and it's impactful and it's more than a
worthwhile watch but you walk out of the
theater feeling like there's so much
that needs to be done yeah if it doesn't
just it's spoon feed you a victory like
so many films do like an archeology dig
where you find some of the artifact but
you haven't you've just seen the tip
exactly exactly you see a little bit of
it and and there are like there are
incredible true stories that are told
through that film about people who were
rescued and obviously seeing anyone
rescued is a wonderful thing to see but
the film doesn't shy away from letting
you know that the problems far from
solved right like the day has has not
been totally saved there's there are
there's work you have to do there's more
children being trafficked today than
when slavery was legal which there's
more slaves there's more slaves in the
world overall yep something what 80
million slaves in the world I think I
think it is true that there are more
child sex slaves today than there were
than there were slaves back when slavery
was legal oh sorry it looks about like
50 million slaves in the world so I was
today but yeah 50 million people in the
world living in slavery as of 2022. how
do you even begin to tackle that I mean
I guess you do what they did and what
Tim Fowler did well in the movie they
bring this up like a lot of this stuff
is happening outside the US we have no
control like it's just not here you know
so that's what Tim Ballard does he goes
and he uh
yeah that guy is unreal I mean I think I
think he's here tomorrow actually oh my
God that's fantastic I Wish I Was Here
let me double shake his hand honestly
say hello bless him
normally we don't but now it's guests in
advance
of Hope
you feel sorrow you feel hope the film
it takes you on a roller coaster but the
film it's not just like it's this
emotional experience that you'll get
from film sometimes where it's totally
aimless and they're just manipulating
you it's giving you a real story
it's giving you Solutions
my goodness with uh Eduardo Vera uh he's
the director of the film correct wow
very excited for that very excited that
is huge gonna be great maybe I'll push
my flight back just I just want to shake
it I know I want to shake a sand too I
just want to say thank you God bless his
wife too I hope I understand with him I
don't know if she's going to take the
trip
his wife is an incredible woman I I was
reading some of the differences between
the film and his real story and I'll let
him share on air what he he wants to
share what he's here because it'll be
more impactful for him but some of what
he said his wife said was like uh in
just her involvement and support is
incredible like what a sacrifice for a
wife to make yeah
but oh geez well we'll go into it
tomorrow this dude's like I know we got
a bunch of kids but I'm Gonna Save a
whole bunch of other people's kids and
she's like okay yeah do it it's crazy
it's it's it's incredible that was when
I first cried is when I I don't wanna I
don't think it's spoiling it but yeah
too soon
you gotta let him see it you gotta let
him see it you people Everyone really
goes I haven't seen it yet you didn't
seen it you you want you want to be a
part of like this is not a film you want
to watch on streaming in a couple months
it really is not like you want to see
this in the theater with fellow audience
members that's a good question it's more
impactful really you will find things
about that yeah because it was it was
pushed pushed around and rebuffed for
five like it's actually shocking that
it's not just an in you know they have
like Indie theaters cities like it's
weird to me that yeah I don't know thank
goodness weird well it's great but how
did that happen thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time